christmas is nearly here and for amazon
it is crunch time it's handling and
trying to deal with the endless stream
of last minute holiday orders amazon's
north las vegas fulfillment center had
to staff up to meet the demand hector
mejia shows us how workers are keeping
pace
with just a few days until christmas the
holiday shipping crunch means
700 000 of those items will get sorted
and go through this facility in one
single day that's over 50 percent more
packages than usual according to general
manager tom smartridge all of our amazon
employees and their families give a lot
they all work extended hours with the
help of technology amazon is racing
against the clock to make sure every
gift makes it under the christmas tree
this is the facility in southern nevada
that uses the robot technology that
orange color you see on the bottom and
essentially how it works is it
communicates with the qr code on the
ground to move around this floor
bringing small items to employees our
pickers and stowers who
traditionally at other companies may
have to walk
many miles a day are able to stay at
their workstation to be safe and we're
also able to optimize our robots to
bring them the customer products the
size of this facility is equivalent to a
hundred eighty basketball courts if an
item is marked for a military member
across the globe it has a special label
on it so it lands where it's supposed to
ship dock operations manager nick
carducci is an army veteran himself it
is a challenge being away from family
and friends especially during the
holidays so
any any type of remnants of being home
and a nice gift and anything that can
connect you to your friends and family
is always a huge deal in north las vegas
hector mejia live local now